White House budget director Mick
Mulvaney joins us from Washington for an
interview you'll see only on CBS this
morning good morning gia mr. Mulvaney
thanks for thanks thank you for having
me thank you very much for joining it so
Congress is starting to work out the
differences between the house and the
Senate bill can you tell us what the
president wants to see now sure the same
thing that we've wanted to see from the
very beginning which is a sort of these
two fundamental principles from the
White House perspective number one
ordinary hardworking Americans will pay
less and it will be simpler for them to
pay and number two this corporate tax
rate will come down it looks like both
the house and the Senate the bills that
have now passed to preserve those two
very important principles so the next
step is to work out the details the
house has some things the Senate doesn't
have and vice versa this is part of the
ordinary course of business and passing
law but we do like to see the progress
that's going on and still on goal for
forgetting it's done by Christmas well
let me ask you this does the president
favor seven rates or four rates we favor
whatever can pass that we'd like a
simpler code keeping in mind that the
number of rates doesn't really change
the simplicity of the code for ordinary
folks they're just simply going to turn
to the booklet in the back of the tax
book and fill out their taxes so it's
gonna be very simple for individual
ordinary Americans regardless of how
many rates there are so as between the
four or five rates that were in the
House bill the six or seven in the
Senate bill were really indifferent it
sounds like you're saying the president
doesn't mind much what's in the bill he
just wants a bill no not at all I said
we want a bill that preserves our
principles and so far these bills both
have those things so we're very excited
about the progress no no it's not a bill
for the sake of passing a bill we need
the substance of this but those two
principles are what have been driving
the White House for the very beginning
well let me ask you about one of the
president's principles because during
the campaign he called the national debt
quote wait around the future of every
young person in this country I mean is
the president concerned that this is
going to add one point four trillion
dollars to the debt listen the debt
continues to be a priority for the White
House I hope that I still have a
reputation for being a deficit Hawk for
a fiscal Hawk I think it's the reason
the president hired me for this job but
keep in mind the deficit is a function
of two different things that the amount
of revenues into the government and the
amount of revenues out so revenues and
spending we need this tax bill to grow
the economy a healthy American economy
where everybody works for
make more money actually generates more
money for the government coffers so one
of the ways we're hoping to reduce the
deficit over the long term is by having
this tax bill passed both bills aimed at
repealing the estate tax of course which
targets the nation's wealthiest last
week Republican Senator Chuck Grassley
told the Des Moines Register I think not
having the estate tax recognizes the
people that are investing as opposed to
those that are just spending every darn
penny they have whether it's on booze or
women or movies so let me ask you is
that a fair characterization of 99.9
percent of US households no I'm not sure
where that's coming from on the estate
tax we would like to see it go away we
do not think that dying should invite
the IRS into your life right now when
you pass away it's a taxable event a
taxable transaction we just don't think
that's right we do believe long-term in
taxing the assets that families have
collected over the generations we just
don't think it should be at the point of
death now the Senate bill would repeal
the Obama care individual mandate that's
something that CBO says would leave 13
million Americans without insurance
is the president okay with that think
about that for a second so what the CBO
is telling you is as soon as the
government tells you you don't have to
buy something you're not going to is
that necessarily a bad thing I mean do
we really want to have some law on the
books this goes back to the underlying
issue of health care and while at the
same time recognizing that the Democrats
have pitched health care as a tax so
it's entirely appropriate to be dealing
with that now that shouldn't government
really be telling you to forcing you to
buy something you don't want to buy
we're absolutely comfortable with that
we're glad the Senate finally got around
to repealing the individual mandate the
house had done it previously in a
separate bill so we're looking forward
to that possibly being part of the final
of the final legislation so both bills
have a cut for the corporate tax rate
down to 20% the president has said he
could go up to 22% you have some
Republican senators that want to do that
because they say they could help more
middle-class families if you just
increased it a couple of percentage
points is that's something where there
could be negotiation sure
again we liked 15% to begin with where
we love that 20% but if it takes a
smaller change in there to get this
across the finish line we're willing to
work on the details with both the House
and the Senate keep in mind it's not
just us that the Senate is negotiating
with they have to negotiate with the
house as well
alright Mick Mulvaney thank you so much
for joining us I think she'll have a
great morning